c'est une grande première depuis deux
ans monti le bretonneux la ville
organisait une compétition
départementale ce samedi 22 et dimanche
23 janvier au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin on avait demandé par tout le
club local pendant deux ans on n'a pas
fait un donc j'ai été le dernier à faire
en 2019 et je suis à un mois le premier
à refaire en baroeul 2022 donc j'ai fait
la dernière et je refais la première
mais ça fait deux ans les filles jouent
bien je parce qu'on est toujours en
protocole sanitaire donc port du masque
obligatoire
juste quand elles passent pas et elles
peuvent l'emmener au sinon on va tout le
monde joue le jeu
j'ai ça ça se passe plutôt bien
[Musique]
au total plus de 400 sportifs venus
d'une vingtaine de clubs du département
avaient fait le déplacement pour renouer
avec la compétition
suit à ses contacts continuent mais
organisé à une compétition parce que sa
première depuis deux ans donc cette
ambiance c'est vrai que ça nous a manqué
à tous donc
ja se contente de
organiser ça donc aujourd'hui c'était
quand ils me rendent kobe décidera ce
moment
de reprendre au besoin
prochain rendez-vous à monti le
bretonneux au mois de mars pour les
championnats interdépartementaux
[Applaudissements]